c'est une vanne alors déjà pour rebondir
ce que j'ai entendu
j'ai vu le prospectus soirée que qu'il
retourne avant de Aurélien
j'aimerais qu'on parte sur une base
neutre allez-y parce que vous êtes
partis avec des fausses identiques je
pense en disant que c'était un bar
affreux blablabla
est-ce qu'on peut voir les vidéos avant
de les voir c'est la j'ai accepté
exceptionnellement que ces vidéos soient
diffusées dernière fois sont diffusés
une dernière fois sur TPMP car il y a eu
de nombreux procès il y a eu des
plaintes qui ont été déposés contre ces
vidéos le jugement était donné en 2020
nous en sommes ressortis totalement
blanchi c'est vidéo sont des montages
atroces d'une chaîne Catari donc vous
allez voir les vidéos c'est ce sera la
dernière fois moi je parle j'ai vu moi
je connaissais pas le bar mais j'ai vu
des vidéos je me suis dit c'est
incroyable mais on parle bien on parle
bien
je vais vous montrer les vidéos si vous
voulez vous voulez vous vous cautionnez
ces vidéos ou pas donc on va voir les
vidéos comme ça on les voit et après
comme ça on va on va pouvoir parler
alors pour ceux qui veulent en savoir un
peu plus sur le bar
on dit voilà il y a un journaliste en
fait ils disent que c'est un journaliste
qui avait infiltré le groupe est filtre
est filmé en caméra cachée c'est ça en
l'occurrence non ce n'est pas aussi un
peu en renseigné c'était pas le
journaliste à militant extrêmes moches
d'accord je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
si ça fait une grosse différence non non
beaucoup journalistes sont extrêmement
gauche
et dans ce pars on prône l'identité et
la violence apparemment et ils sont
fiers de parler de ratona et de salut
nazis regardez
un groupe les c'était une dizaine 7 mecs
ah c'est chaud quand il voulait se
Battice balader avec leur magnum de
gripouze et tout ça les grosses
bouteilles et ça a fini Rémy arrive
creuse droite de tentant un bruit mais
bon comme ça j'ai jamais entendu je
voulais vraiment aller casser les casser
avec une fissure là qui commence à
pisser le sang mais de l'autre c'est
Rémi qui la Metz ok et tu as les filles
de leur boucles qui sont imposées
et ils sont barrés en courant chez on
les a chargés
alors ça c'est la première vidéo on va
toutes les voir un peu comme ça qu'on
pourra pour discuter là
on parle d'attentat contre des mosquées
c'est le cas d'un monsieur qui s'appelle
Rémi Falise vous connaissez apparemment
c'est le seul que je connaisse dans
cette vidéo dans toutes ces vidéos en
ligne regardez le jour où je sais que
j'ai une maladie incurable mec je
m'achète une arme que fait un carnage
Charlie Hebdo à côté c'est de la pisse
de chien
une mosquée n'importe quoi
allez Archer
[Musique]
mais tu fais un bordel ça c'était dans
votre barre
tout à fait
c'est très grave ça c'est très grave
il y a eu des sanctions on va dérouler
alors il y a c'est un petit groupe qui
traîne avec des personnes de réel
néo-nazis et comme dans un autre
barlinois lors d'une soirée regardez ça
c'est un autre bar ça je voudrais dire
ça là ce qu'on voit c'est dans un autre
bar tout à fait
c'est juste hallucinant regardez et ce
ne sont pas des gens de chez nous
[Musique]
j'ai fait n'importe quoi programmer sur
les bars
[Musique]
hamburger
Kings
et malheureusement donc le journaliste
infiltrait plus constater de ses yeux
que la violence était
omniprésente dans ce groupe dès lors
qu'il croise une personne d'origine
étrangère
allez les enfants
[Musique]
la réalité nous ici on monte la réalité
on veut pas se voiler la face et
justement on veut faire réagir les gens
parce que ça ça c'est une admissible
excusez-moi non mais franchement ça je
peux on peut pas cautionner alors ça
c'était pas dans votre barre mais que
dans votre barre se passe des choses
comme ça Aurélien
j'ai vu j'ai vu le prospectus c'est ce
qu'on a le prospectus voilà avec les
soirées qui se passe dans votre bas
voilà alors programme donc bon bah
soirée les Bobards d'Or donc tracteur
très bien il y a un apéro patriote le
vendredi 10 et ça cette soirée là
vendredi 24 soirée spéciale qu'il
retourne en Afrique c'est quoi est-ce
que je peux revenir d'abord sur les
extraits vidéo parce que c'est important
la dernière fois qu'on les verra la télé
sans qu'il y a de plantes on a déposé
jugement été fait sur ce sur tout ce
reportage qui en fait un reportage
fallacieux avec des montages temples
le début le début le fou que vous voyez
que les IgA etc je ne le connais pas je
ne l'ai jamais vu de ma vie il n'est
jamais venu à l'estadel on ne sait même
pas qui c'est on a déposé contre lui car
on soupçonne même que c'est un
journaliste parce que pour dire autant
de mots clés vous voyez ça c'est la
phrase c'est même pas monté c'est le mec
qui a sorti les mots clés machin mais
qui dit ça dans la vraie vie dans la
réalité je regarde que personne je ne
sais pas donc on a entre cette porte
cette personne parce que vous êtes le
président pourtant vous connaissez tous
vos membres c'est un club privé mais
c'est pas mon gars et c'est pas méchant
ah oui tout à fait
tout ce que vous voyez là le seul membre
de tout ce que vous voyez là c'est Rémi
Falise d'accord je dis des atrocités que
j'ai dénoncé à nombreuses reprises il a
été viré car nous ne sommes pas chez les
filles quand quelqu'un fait de la merde
on le vire hein donc c'était le seul
tout ce que vous voyez le reste c'est
passé devant les tribunaux imaginez la
Rémy Falise bien sûr il n'a plus jamais
mis les pieds vous savez on a 1350
adhérents et c'est quoi en fait on a mis
350 adhérents de temps en temps oui
quand il y a l'alcool il y a des fous
furieux il faut simplement que le que la
structure
sur le tribunal je termine sur les
tribunal c'est que ça a été jugé je n'ai
même pas été cité au tribunal en tant
que témoin la stadel n'a même pas été
distante tant que témoin tant le juge
qui a demandé à Jazeera les montages
sans les vidéos sans montage je le dira
a refusé alors je vais tout ça ce n'est
que des mensonges tous les gens
justement Aurélien les gens vous voyez
les machines c'est pas des gens de chez
nous pensons que c'est des journalistes
Aurélien
c'est une maison de l'identité qui a été
créée en 2015 alors qu'est-ce que c'est
une maison vous allez me dire voilà bah
c'est très bien c'est un lieu de vie
enraciné pour les gens qui refusent la
culture globale et la et la et la et la
taxe sur nos identités nos identités qui
peuvent être condéfendent ou triple qui
peuvent être régionales donc en
l'occurrence flamand vu qu'on est à
Lille française donc nationale et
européenne civilisationnel donc de là la
citadelle on ne fait le bar c'est on est
ouvert que le vendredi dans 4 90% des
activités de la citadelle c'est le bar
était fermé justement le vendredi en
fait c'est pas un bar c'est une maison
identique un bar stricte au sang sur il
doit avoir une licence
nous on est une association le 1901 et
les gens payent pour faire c'est dire
aux parents bon si exceptionnellement si
vous venez non non vous avez apporté une
carte d'adhérent
alors les critères c'est simple ça
toujours été clair
aujourd'hui la définition de la patrie
c'est quelqu'un qui aime qui aime la
France qui aime son pays qui vit selon
ses coutumes ses lois tout simplement je
vais ce n'est pas les immigrés quand
même alors attendez je vais vous donner
un exemple on aime bien la France on
aime bien on aime la France on adore la
France on est heureux ici est-ce qu'on
pourrait de la bière ou pas parce que on
est enfant
bien sûr bien sûr vraiment
un poisson comme un poisson dans l'eau
de différentes religions il n'y en a pas
beaucoup d'accord il n'y a pas beaucoup
de raisons simple c'est que pour une
raison simple on va on va pas se mentir
nous sommes en France nous sommes un
pays de marins de marchand des apports
extérieurs donc d'extraopiens il y en a
toujours eu à travers l'histoire genre
le nier et grotesque je ne l'ai jamais
je n'ai jamais dit je ne le dirai jamais
oui il y a des il y a des Français
d'origine s'il vous plaît
revenir sur un truc qui est très
important pour moi c'est ce prospectus
ça emmenez-moi montrez-moi le prospectus
s'il vous plaît merci rapidement avec
cette soirée vous auriez vous auriez dû
mettre le vrai le vrai prospective de la
soirée non c'est pas c'est ça ou pas le
le retourne en Afrique ça c'est le
programme le prospectus c'est beaucoup
plus parlant non non mais non mais le
programme c'est quoi ça qui retourne à
la base c'est comme le port salut c'est
marqué dessus hein c'est qu'il retourne
en Afrique
on reprend voilà je reprenais je
reprenais les termes du député de
Fournas à l'Assemblée nationale quand
vous mettez au pluriel vous mettez au
pluriel je pense que au niveau de je
pense que c'est toujours été au pluriel
concernant le la polémique qui a eu sur
la chaîne vide pour vous pourrez donc
c'est vous le mettez dans la sauce en
plus non pas du tout non d'accord oui
donc je reprenais ce que disait de
Fornas en disant en parlant notamment de
la chaîne Viking en disant voilà tous
les bateaux de migrants clandestin qui
arrive
qu'il retourne en Afrique pas du tout
c'est quoi le thème de la soirée
retourne en Afrique bah c'est faire
c'est faire c'est faire bah d'ailleurs
c'était c'était pour soutenir le député
de Fournas donc qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
on a commandé 120 parce que des
bouteilles de Fournas est également
vignerons et on a les proposer aux gens
de manger du saucisson et de boire du
vin c'était je pense que c'est pas
encore interdit en 2023 en France et
c'est tant mieux peut-être que bientôt
on sait jamais Gilles bah c'est
tellement raciste que le parquet a
ouvert quand même une information pour
provocation publique à la haine et c'est
tellement raciste que effectivement vous
étiez un club privé mais comme la mairie
de Lille a réussi à prouver que vous
receviez du public elle a trouvé le bien
pour vous fermer et Monsieur moi ce que
je voulais vous demander c'est il y a eu
des scènes de violence tout à l'heure
c'est scène de violence dans votre
barroyeur est-ce que vous les condamnez
ces scènes de violence alors je les ai
condamné déjà à l'époque alors surtout
que non mais
les trois quarts des trucs que vous avez
vu ce n'est pas dans mon bar et tout ça
si la
consommer tranquillement scène pour
laquelle vous avez d'ailleurs été
condamné par la justice est-ce que vous
monsieur de quoi vous monsieur verra ça
c'est bien c'est bien vous qui avez été
condamné pour avoir attaqué deux
personnes en terrasse jamais jamais
vous avez été condamné mais là je sais
pas comment vous avez parlé 5 mois ferme
ah non alors là on parle de la alors là
si on parle on parle des on peut en
parler si vous voulez
retourne en Afrique
vanter des custations du vin voilà donc
ce que vous avez dit donc du vieux
Cassin on se tient un député courageux
d'accord 24 février à la citadelle 8 rue
des arts il est venu le député non non
il dit les mots c'est pour lui envoyer
un peu de force alors avant qu'on soit
en pause Gilles vous a posé une question
vous allez répondre vous voulez lui
reposer pour que les téléspectateurs
avec plaisir je disais monsieur verra
celle que vous condamniez la violence
qu'on voyait sur des vidéos tournées
dans votre bac dans un autre bar pas
raciste mais que vous-même mais que j'ai
pas utilisé le mot là mais que vous-même
ét si je puis dire une sorte d'apôtre de
la violence puisqu'en 2015 j'avais
attaqué deux personnes à table dans un
bar et que vous avez été condamné pour
cela et vous avez répondu je porte mes
condamnations comme un triomphe
donc ce que vous avez vu le PV de cette
altercation vous l'avez vu vous l'avez
lu non j'ai pas lu le PV j'ai vu votre
condamnation à 5 mois ferme mais vous
l'avez vu dans Libération je pense que
c'est le seul journal que vous lisez une
technique
j'ai été agressé par deux racailles
dealer place de Strasbourg à Lille à 5h
du matin en sortant de boîte j'étais à
Cannes mes amis ils nous ont dit ça va
les petits [__] je cite
suite à ça il y en a un ils sont venus
nous attaquer et oui ils ont pris une
route phénoménale d'accord car dans la
France de 2022 à l'époque oui mieux vaut
faire de la boxe du tennis mon ami et
moi faisant de la boxe ils ont pris une
route et en fait on n'a pas été joué
pour aller ils ont dit la justice a dit
que la réponse était disproportionnée
par rapport à l'attaque donc et donc
j'étais condamné ouais
refaire demain mais je le recherche de
personnes et d'avoir compris
efficace alors Aurélien
verra celle donc président de la
citadelle la citadelle est fermée alors
ça y est justement non euh
bravo à Gérald Darmanin il bosse Gira il
a il a vu cette soirée il a interdit que
la soirée il y avait interdit la soirée
c'est lui qui a poussé pour fermer le
bar ah voilà il a contacté le préfet
il a bougé donc souvent la préfecture la
soirée n'est même pas interdite du tout
parce qu'elle n'est pas illégale et
d'après la mairie c'est un arrêté
municipal qui ne vise pas la soirée qui
ne dit pas que la soirée est illégale
qui dit aujourd'hui que notre
association qui était un club privé est
devenu un ERP soudainement sauf que
l'association Le Barp c'est un état
rendu public parce que les gens n'ont
pas de temps que Martine Aubry nous a
fait de nombreuses procédures qu'elles
ne le découvre pas on appelle ça on
appelle ça comme l'aliment avocat un
détournement de pouvoir c'est une notion
de droit administratif
s'est arrêté va sauter la soirée du 24
aura lieu et je vous y invite tous il
faudra adhérer
deux minutes parce que j'ai un truc
important dans une interview vous disiez
pour être dans notre bar il faut être
français européen et la base oui c'est
d'être de race blanche ça interview de à
l'époque télé qui est totalement coupé
car je n'ai je n'ai fait à ce moment là
j'ai cité de la terre
je remercie ciel de m'inviter est-ce que
là je peux m'exprimer un peu plus
longuement ça me manque les journalistes
c'est oui ils ont trois ils ont 3
minutes vous faites 1h30 d'interview
c'est pas vous que je vais prendre ça et
ben oui ils prennent le truc le plus
croustillant sauf qu'en fait ces
citations et c'est une citation qui fait
une partie qui fait partie de la station
de De Gaulle par la fit qui dit nous
sommes avant tout un pays d'orage blanc
de culture grécolatine mais oui il y a
également des apports extérieurs jaunes
noires c'est ça qui fait la beauté de la
France et son univers signal sanitaire
c'est ça que j'ai dit en totalité sauf
que ils ont retient ils ont retenu que
ça forcément quand on coupe
on est d'accord je connais des Noirs qui
sont des gens fiers de leur racine qui
vivent je fais beaucoup de box qui
vivent qui vivent en Afrique qui sont
fiers de leur racine en France ils
peuvent pas vivre en France soyons
simples on peut intégrer la France peut
intégrer des individus on ne peut pas
intégrer des peuples entiers imaginez
que d'après un sondage 52% des jeunes
Africains de ligue 24 ans veulent venir
en France le Nigéria fait plus d'enfants
que la totalité de l'Europe réunit le
ninja c'est 220 millions d'habitants
l'Europe 450 millions mais s'ils
viennent tous en France on les met où je
veux bien je suis d'accord avec vous on
les invite tous on fait venir un
milliard d'Africains en France on fait
une grosse fête une grosse somme en tout
son arrière entre copains et après on y
va ça sera pas parce que vous votre
projet c'est quoi c'est de les mettre
qui finissent à la chapelle dans la
colline du crack parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on leur propose aussi Sylviane c'est
ça aussi la question s'il vous plaît
juste Delphine après
le mot racisme vous pique les oreilles
mais entre ce que vous vous faites et le
racisme c'est quoi la différence
moi je n'ai jamais été condamné
je repose la question parce que comme ça
vous pouvez un peu vous expliquer entre
ce que vous vous faites ce que vous
soutenez ce que vous prenez et le
racisme quelle est la différence il faut
poser les mots c'est quoi le racisme
pour vous
comme je le disais moi je défends à la
fois les cultures papoule les cultures
Massaï d'accord je voyage beaucoup je
défends la totalité du pluralisme des
cultures vous voyez quand je vais quand
je vais quand je vais en Afrique quand
chez eux quand je vais en Afrique j'ai
envie de voir des Africains vous voyez
j'ai pas envie de voir quand je vais à
Marrakech j'ai pas envie de voir une
bande de Parisiens
ivre et cocker vous voyez j'ai envie de
voir des Marocains fier de leur culture
et les magiciens
les synagogues en France en France tout
est une question de nombre une non le
fait qu'il y en ait aujourd'hui 2000 oui
ça me pose un problème parce que en fait
il y a il y a un changement de
population qui s'opère et ça me prend un
problème parce que comme le disait
Dingo le grand
c'est des chiffres
admettez que c'est pas un hasard malgré
tout que vous soyez dans le viseur de du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
vous êtes un des fondateurs du mouvement
identitaire qui s'appelle génération
identitaire qui a été dissout et
maintenant il y a cette il y a ce bar
qui pose également problème avec cette
thématique qui pose également problème
c'est c'est que donc vous êtes un
merveilleux rétor parce que à chaque
fois vous essayez de nous embrouiller et
de jouer avec les lignes mais vous dites
pas réellement le sang de votre pensée
je dis que vous jouez avec les mots et
que vous ne dites pas réellement le fond
de votre pensée
mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez du fond
de ma pensée je lui dis que je vous
défends la totalité des cultures du
monde et c'est le principe de la
citadelle expliquez-nous ce flyer là
il y a des migrants là-haut il y a des
plaques expliquez-moi
c'est la phase de fournaisse
les clandestins doivent retourner dans
leur pays d'origine pas forcément en
Afrique d'ailleurs mais dans leur pays
d'origine je parle bien des clandestins
je parle pas des Français d'origine
étrangère qui sont eux français c'est
comme si moi je faisais une soirée si
vous êtes aussi si vous tous dans le
fort Boyard si vous voulez si vous
voulez que tous les si vous voulez que
les clandestins qui sont des là on est
là de manière illégal reste en France
c'est votre problème mais l'inégalité de
votre côté à vous pas du mien je vais
sur les clandestins il y a 80 à 90% des
occulter qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
appliqués donc qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
c'est quoi le projet on les met à la
colline du crack qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
tous ces gens j'ai vu le reportage juste
avant oui ben voilà maintenant il
servent ils servent de manœuvre à bas
coût à des patrons voyous et ils sont en
concurrence directement avec nos pauvres
je vous remercie suffisamment de pauvres
en France pour ne pas accepter tous les
pauvres de la ville Verdez vous êtes
tellement d'extrême droite que même
génération identitaire ne veut plus de
vous c'est-à-dire que les associations
en France les plus d'extrême droite
disent ce gars là on en veut plus
monsieur là l'idéologie que vous prenez
c'est purement la haine de l'autre c'est
la provocation à la haine c'est la haine
de l'autre c'est je déteste les noirs et
les Arabes c'est ce que vous pensez
pourquoi vous le dites pas explicitement
c'est ce que vous incarnez une France
blanche uniquement avec des blancs pour
des blancs c'est pas l'argent
aujourd'hui
c'est l'histoire vous professez ici la
haine de l'autre monsieur et d'ailleurs
je vais vous dire une meilleure chose
c'est que on a déposé 8 plaintes suite
au truc d'Aljazeera au truc d'algésira
et il y a il y a deux il y a 5 ans
aujourd'hui il y a la semaine dernière
il y a deux plantes qui viennent de pris
en compte par la par la magistrature il
y a deux mises en examen qui viennent
d'être pris en compte par des gens assez
connus du PAF qui sont sortis de l'AFP
le sortir la semaine prochaine
c'est-à-dire là je suis un mec sympa
donc je peux pas contre vous selon un
débat vous voyez mais pour ce que vous
avez aimé
mais prochainement voilà comment ça se
passe est-ce que vous avez tort vous
avez tort vous êtes un menteur alors
excusez-moi c'est vrai que vous vendez
des t-shirts anti racailles dans dans
votre établissement ou pas et quelle
c'est ce que disent les gens sur les
réseaux on en avait il y avait il y a eu
une série de t-shirts on en vend pas il
y a une série de t-shirts à manger alors
qu'est-ce que c'est la racaille pour
vous ah bah c'est les gens qui regardent
les c'est les mecs qui emmènent les gens
là je peux pas être plus clair c'est où
la raquette il y a pas de couleur
stricte au sang dessus oui est-ce que
vous pouvez tomber amoureux de quelqu'un
d'origine africaine au maghrébine ou
selon vous les blondes doivent pas se
mélanger selon vos idées
alors encore une fois je vis je ne vise
pas des individus donc en fait ça veut
dire que ça peut arriver ça peut arriver
est-ce que l'amour ne se contrôle pas
vers un moment c'est pas l'état si un
jour j'avais au pouvoir admettons ce
sera bientôt j'espère l'amour ne se
contrôle pas donc donc ça ça arrive et
ça arrive et je ne l'interdis pas moi
clairement je préfère sortir avec du
genre je suis avec une blanche et je
suis très bien avec elle est-ce que vous
pouvez pas préférer passer une soirée
avec des des racistes ou avec des des
Mokhtar et moi
d'après vous le mais peut-être que votre
car est raciste je sais pas moi
peut-être moi j'en connais pas
d'ailleurs si vous en connaissez plus
que moi apparemment moi j'en connais pas
donc voilà je fasse pas de foire avec
eux vous avez dit tout à l'heure parce
qu'il y avait peut-être trop de de
mosquées ou trop de synagogues par
exemple il y a cinq ou six millions de
je vais pas parler de single si vous
avez dit il en faut pas ah donc une
différence
à Paris ah donc vous avez un problème
par rapport aux musulmans alors il y a
pas forcément musulman jamais
il y a des musulmans il y a des
musulmans comme les harkis qui sont des
gens très bien et qui se comportent bien
il y a plein
moi je pars du principe qu'il y a des
cons partout moi
ça fait ça non parce que là on parlait
des mosquées vous avez dit le nom de
quasiment français ne compatriotes
est-ce que vous trouvez quand il y en a
trop oui
il y a pas assez on nous dit toujours et
il y a pas assez de mosquée mais c'est
simplement qu'il y a trop de musulmans
oui il y a trop de musulmans en France
et alors c'est musulmans ça veut dire
quoi ça
veut dire non si on va au bout de votre
raisonnement puisque vous dites qu'il y
a trop de musulmans en France aller au
bout de votre raisonnement qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que qu'est-ce
que vous voulez faire des musulmans qui
sont en France et français des Français
de religion musulmane des citoyens
français et reste en France je parle
depuis tout à l'heure j'en ai parlé mais
je parle bien des clandestins faire des
gens qui n'ont rien à faire sur notre
territoire qui seront visés à un moment
donné par un QF qui ne sera pas
appliquée je ne parle que de ça hein
je ne parle pas des Français
les mecs sur les vidéos c'est des voyous
français de religion musulmanes très
content qu'ils soient avec nous je suis
pas du tout content qu'il soit avec nous
je pense je pense le problème c'est qu'à
un moment c'est le poids le poids de la
démographie du poids des musulmans qui
va qui va comme au Kosovo à m'en faire
basculer simplement donc moi ce que je
veux c'est que qu'il retourne chez eux
en paix pour vivre la religion
français ils sont françaises bah alors
souvent souvent ils sont de double
nationalité mais je mais qui retourne en
fait qui retourne en terre d'Islam car
la France
de retourner chez lui
[Rires]
il est exquis il est il est exquis
seulement
je suis persuadé attention je suis
persuadé que il y en a plein qui se
comporterait qui se comporte très bien
bah non non mais tout le monde
mais comme j'ai dit moi il y a des cons
partout en fait on est une question de
nombre on peut intégrer des individus
des individus on peut pas intégrer des
peuples entiers tout simplement c'est
tout bon
on ferait votre débat dans votre barre
est-ce qu'il va remplir le bar il va
ouvrir le bar ou pas il va rouvrir le
bas alors je vous assure que la soirée
contrairement à ce qu'a dit le troubadur
la France insoumise avec Guillaume la
sœur du 24 aura lieu le l'arrêter
préfectoral le municipale municipal va
sauter à coup sûr mais Martine Aubry est
tellement poussé par son extrême gauche
qu'elle était contrainte malheureusement
de faire quelque chose j'en veux pas
cette à cette brève d'âme donc bien sûr
qu'elle aura lieu bien sûr c'est évident
merci d'avoir été agile ça va non merci
en tout cas merci vous avez
[Musique]
je suis tétanisé parce que tu dégages
comme n de l'autre alors dans toi même
dans tes yeux de la haine et ça me
tétanise que j'aime pas la haine moi je
bute par amour de mon peuple pas par un
des autres pour ta rédemption tu devrais
écouter des musulmans qui sont
parfaitement intégrés qui vivent très
bien dans la société française qui l'ont
bossé le matin et qui sont très contents
tout à fait et arrête de les haïr arrête
de les haïr arrête mais il y en a il y
en a j'ai mis l'inverseur
99,9% monsieur voilà j'ai dit ça non
c'est moi qui te le dis vous avez
beaucoup de chiffres hein mais vous
savez pas trop ce que vous racontez
merci